This course has five lessons that
are depicted in this course map.
But, before we dive into them,
it's important to have a firm
understanding of network basics.
So, we're going to start with
what I'm calling lesson zero.
In this lesson, we're going to
talk about how apps send and
receive data over the network.
Then, we'll show you how to implement
this concept in iOS, using Swift.
We'll do this by building a very
simple app that downloads an image
over the network and
displays it to users.
Also as we go through the lesson,
we'll be keeping track of terms and
concepts in a concept list to
help us keep everything straight.
You'll see it in just a minute.
Let's get started by
inspecting some popular apps.